soir de l'élection fédérale de 2015
le coup était dur pour les conservateurs
en fait foi compliqué les conservateurs
n'ont jamais fait un aussi mauvais score
en atlantique depuis la considération
d'un seul trait l'atlantique étaient
peintes en rouge
du jamais vu sur tout nouveau brunswick
où le vote est souvent divisée selon la
langue de traditionnellement nouveau
brunswick les les acadiens et les
francophones avaient tendance à boîtier
libéral donc les catholiques les
irlandais aussi et de l'autre côté les
anglophones surtout protestants voter
conservateur c'est un peu le fond du
nouveau brunswick le fond le fond de la
vie politique au nouveau brunswick
cette tradition pourrait refaire surface
selon les sondages et les experts mais
avec des looks plus chaud dans les
circonscriptions à majorité anglophone
que dans celle à majorité francophone
direction nouveau brunswick sud ouest
une circonscription anglais
quant à yoann savary ce n'est qu'une
sorte de rêve
mais on sent quand même que la bataille
s'annonce plus serré voilà ce que les
hommes à beauséjour une circonscription
majoritairement francophone même si le
candidat libéral ministre sortant
dominique leblanc n'a pas fait campagne
parce qu'il subit des traitements pour
un cancer on doute peu de sa victoire
oui je pense que libéral va rentrer
encore même coeur et malone pied on y
enregistre moi d'habitude
david oui même les anglophones du coin
en sont persuadés et le chili
yes cette division linguistique serait
moins marquée cette fois chez les jeunes
et sondage laisse croire qu'ils vont
voter pour des partis plus progressif et
accessoires prochaine on a vu que c'est
comment libérer les consommateurs qui
avaient plutôt et leguide com qu'on peut
dire donc ça serait faut en avoir une
nouvelle nouvelle tête à venir la tête
oui bleus ou rouges traditionnellement
les jeunes pourraient ajouter de la
couleur et les à céret radio canada 21